okay here's a clever little media bias
story have you heard of ms-13 ms-13 is a
criminal gang that started in Los
Angeles in the 1980s and it's spread to
a lot of the Western Hemisphere Canada
Mexico down into Central America maybe
even northern South America and the
members are mostly Central American in
fact they're particularly from El
Salvador that's the background in the
wake of Donald Trump's decision to end
daca and presumably to open the door to
start deporting people who came to the
US as the children of undocumented
immigrants Breitbart ran a story with
some really scary-looking people and the
headline was 2139 daca recipients
convicted or accused of crimes against
Americans and you see the picture and
you assume these people that were
looking at these must be the daca
recipients that the article is talking
about the problem is the picture was not
of daca recipients it was actually a
picture from January of 2013 of ms-13
gang members not in the United States
with daca benefits but just people in El
Salvador
this was outed Breitbart was outed
Breitbart ultimately deleted the tweet
about the story and the picture of the
story was replaced with one of some guy
in handcuffs so it's deceptive it's
disgusting it's happened before
right-wing media using footage from
somewhere in Europe I believe it was in
a story about Hispanic immigrants poring
over the us-mexico border I don't know
if you remember that when it was a year
and a half or two years ago during the
Trump campaign you know every news
agency is going to make a mistake from
time to time have to retract a story or
maybe they're using a picture that's
just not appropriate for the story
doesn't represent it correctly yeah I
think they've gone far past that here
because this was a hit piece to begin
with and it just makes it look like this
is representative of all daca recipients
which is clearly not the case not only
that here's the really wacky part and
I'm glad you brought up the sort of
reality empirical realities let's go to
the numbers the article says 2139 daca
recipients convicted or acute
of crimes against Americans the or
accused is a key part but I'll deal with
that in a second
the numbers are because there are
800,000 daca recipients that means 0.26
percent of daca recipients have been
convicted or accused of crimes for
comparison 8.5% of all Americans age 23
and under have been arrested and
convicted of felonies so not only that
0.26 percent of daca recipients were
convicted or accused and as we know in
the United States it's not that rare
that someone is accused of something
that they are ultimately not convicted
of and it actually makes perfect sense
I don't know why people don't get that
if you have no legal status in the US
you're an undocumented immigrant or if
you're on daca
if you're in a daca situation and you
have a potentially precarious legal
status which could be maybe overturned
you're not going to commit more crime
than the average American you're gonna
commit less crime because you don't want
to draw attention to yourself because
you're aware of your precarious legal
status it's not as if if you commit a
serious crime that you shouldn't face
repercussions know that you can go to
jail you can go to prison but you
shouldn't be deported to a country that
you've never known especially come over
here when you're just a few years old
this is why media literacy is so key and
critical thinking has never been more
important and I'm interestingly I'm
teaching this journalism class
communication class on new media to talk
media rather at Boston College the first
two classes have all been about critical
thinking epistemology and media literacy
so that before we even start getting
into more nitty-gritty media stuff we've
got to be able to analyze these stories
oh wow 2139 daca recipients have been
convicted or accused of crimes well out
of how many and how does that concern
how does that compare to the underlying
crime rate in the United States without
that information the headline is worth
nothing aside from the deceptive picture
you're talking about a country of 300
million people you're talking about
800,000 daca recipients if you just put
the raw numbers in there it's going to
sound like a lot percentages sound a lot
smaller very very different situation
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum David
mancom /r e d di t back after this break
today's sponsor is taga dab the hosting
specialists whatever your hosting needs
for your business or project taga dab
can do it dedicated servers virtual
private servers cloud server solutions
colocation custom server solutions and
the big thing at taga dab is their
customer support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
this is a testament to the great support
that they give their customers currently
rated a nine point seven out of 10
according to the Trustpilot review
system with a growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects to the cloud taga dab
currently offers our viewers and
listeners a twenty british pound free
credit about twenty four US dollars to
all new customers that sign up gives you
a chance to try the service this is a
limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up taga DAB
comm /td PS and use the offer code TDPS
20 during account registration support
our sponsors and support our show in
doing so sign up ta ga da be com /t DPS
coupon code is TDPS 20